(bright music)
Dr. Vail is no stranger to board review.
Belinda is the chair in the Department of Family Medicine
at the University of Kansas.
And she is going to be leading our discussion
on obesity and metabolic syndrome.
So, Belinda, good morning, and take it away, ma'am.
Thank you.
We're going to see the field of obesity medicine
just change dramatically over the next few years.
And what happens I think is totally up in the air.
So we'll talk about the new weight loss drugs here.
The obesity trend right now has been for years to just,
the map has changed every year
to get darker and darker and darker.
They had to change the colors
because we were just becoming as a nation, so rapidly obese.
Notice on there,
2/3 of Americans are either overweight or obese.
So we have a lot, there's a lot of work to do.
And he gave you the definitions.
Overweight is a BMI of 25 or more.
Obesity, 30 or more.
In children, you have to use the graphs.
It's 85 percentile for overweight, 95 percentile for obese.
This is what the graph looks like.
It's because in normal children,
their BMI goes down to a nadir
at about five or six years of age
and then rises after that.
So you have to use the graphs
and use gender for this as well as age.
Metabolic syndrome,
please just know the definition of this.
You have to have three of the five things
that I have listed here to meet the criteria.
There are a lot of different organizations who define this,
so they may not use the exact same numbers,
particularly for fasting glucose and for blood pressure.
Those might be slightly different numbers,
but they're all going to be using an elevated number.
And pretty much everybody uses
the same definitions for weight circumference,
40 inches in men, 35 in women.
And the same numbers for HDL and triglycerides.
So what we're looking at is dyslipidemia,
low HDL and high triglycerides.
And so if you just have that dyslipidemia
and only need one other thing to have,
the metabolic syndrome.
Also know the diagnose or the definition for prediabetes,
it's an A1c of 5.7 to 6.4.
It's pretty big.
But what we're seeing with type 2 diabetes is
a very insidious, slow onset.
And so you don't have not diabetes and now diabetes.
It's a progression to get there.
And the quicker we interfere in that progression,
the better off the patient is.
The implications of obesity, we know those,
there are a lot of them.
You have a risk of a lot of different diseases,
including the number one killers like heart disease.
Please note on the cancers.
Overall, if you look at all cancers,
a lot of cancers are actually decreasing,
but the obesity related cancers are increasing,
and that's a number of them.
All the female cancers are obesity related,
particularly uterine cancer.
And then the GI tract cancers are obesity related.
And particularly gallbladder disease.
And so gallbladder cancers are on the rise as well.
And then you'll see
there's kind of an odd conglomeration of other cancers
that are obesity related,
kidney, meningiomas, leukemia, and thyroid.
We wanna start preventing obesity in childhood in the womb.
So the less the mother gains,
the less likely the child is to develop obesity
later on in life.
There are a lot of other things we can do,
making sure they breastfeed,
making sure they get that physical activity.
And you see there,
the two important things on this slide are the screening,
which Dr. Weismiller noted.
We screen everyone starting at six.
That's USPSTF recommendation.
And then we offer everyone these comprehensive programs,
higher intensity, multicomponent behavioral programs,
which require a lot of touch base with the patient.
So again not you need to lose weight, see you in six months,
but you need to lose weight, let's put you in a program,
we're gonna talk to you every couple of weeks.
That's sort of thing.
That's the way to get patients to lose weight.
43-year-old female has been struggling to lose weight.
In reviewing her medications,
which of the following is likely to be making weight loss
substantially more difficult for her?
Escitalopram, lisinopril, mirtazapine, or bupropion?
Excellent, mirtazapine.
And for some reason the boards like this,
this particular one,
you know, your patients always like to blame it on you.
Well it's, you know, or their glands.
You know, it's a gland problem that they have, you know?
Yeah, so you don't eat it,
you eat too much and you don't exercise enough,
but I'm sure there's a gland problem as well.
So but there are other reasons
and we do need to check for those things.
And we do give patients medications a lot
that make it easier for them to gain weight.
And so be thinking of medications that you can use
that help them lose weight,
not medications that make them gain.
And so the anti-seizure meds are particularly bad.
The second generation antipsychotics
and the antidepressants.
Most of the SSRIs are actually either weight neutral
or help them lose.
But be cautious in all of these.
All right, diets.
We could talk for the whole time just on diets.
There's diets, some diets work for some people,
some diets work for other people.
Most diets are only effective
for a reasonably short period of time.
Usually about six months gets you maximum weight loss.
And then sometimes people will continue
to lose weight for up to two years.
And then they tend to start gaining that weight back again.
So diets are very difficult for patients to stay on.
They need to change the relationship with food
and their lifestyle and the way they live,
not just the way they eat.
So I'm just going to eat this.
This is why diets like high-protein diets,
you know, people tend to lose weight on those,
but then over a period of time they're just,
I can't stay on a diet.
You can stay on a lifestyle change
if you change the way you eat
and you change your relationship with food.
But when you have a diet,
you have things that you can't eat
and things that you can't do
and that doesn't work for people,
not over a long period of time.
Please know the numbers of the kilocalories in a pound,
there are 3,500 kilocalories in a pound.
So if you cut your calories 500 a day for seven days,
that's 3,500, that's a pound, okay?
And I actually one time on the boards had to calculate that.
So a 27-year-old female with a BMI of 39
requests help with the diet.
You tell her there's no weight loss diet
that's better than the others.
The Mediterranean diet is the best weight loss diet.
Decreasing intake by 500 calories a day
will result in the recommended two-pound weekly weight loss.
And avoid the commercial weight loss programs
because they don't produce results.
Very good.
There just is no diet that's like the,
you know, the panacea diet.
And every year, every magazine you pick up,
there's a new diet,
every year there's a new fad diet.
The Mediterranean diet is the best diet.
So there are variations of the Mediterranean diet.
The DASH diet is one of those.
The new one, the rave this year's the portfolio diet.
So it's much, it's a plant-based,
a lot of plant protein, not so much animal protein,
but it's not a total vegetarian diet.
Again, those very low carbohydrate diets are,
if you want rapid weight gain, they're the best,
but they tend to not be able to be sustained.
In kids, we know that diet alone, exercise alone,
neither of those work anywhere nearly as well
as putting the two together.
And this eating meals as a family every day has been shown
to really improve patients' perception of themselves,
we're talking kids and teens here.
And looking at better attitudes about food.
And so,
we're seeing more and more weight loss programs now
concentrating on the family unit.
So parent and child dyads
and not just let's pick the child out
and try to get them to lose weight.
It really, it's a family affair, it truly is.
For diabetes, these are the changes that are helpful,
again, a Mediterranean style diet.
More seafood, whole grains, fruits, veggies, low fat dairy,
more potassium, calcium, vitamin D, magnesium,
and particularly B12 in the diet.
It's better to put things in the diet
than to put them into a pill.
So if you can get them in the diet much, much better.
So you have a 37-year-old male with a BMI of 35
and would like to lose weight without changing his diet,
but with daily moderate-intensity exercise, you tell him.
He should not expect to lose weight with exercise alone.
If he adds dietary changes,
he will likely have substantial weight loss.
Adding exercise will likely be
moderately beneficial for weight loss.
Or he should expect significant weight loss
if he exercises daily for at least 60 minutes.
Well, when we're talking about diet and exercise,
if the word moderate is in it, you should pick that.
Because substantial just doesn't,
diet and exercise just doesn't get you substantial
in most cases.
So adding exercise will be moderately beneficial.
And here again,
the number that you're gonna see over and over on the boards
is 150 minutes a week of moderate exercise.
Moderate exercise, that's the recommendation.
Again, if you're going to lose weight,
you're gonna have to bump that up.
And there was just a study out that showed
that 300 minutes a week is what you really need
to have peak effect on your cardiovascular.
So, and for the most healthy,
you need to get to 300 minutes a week.
And it was it effective,
much more so for women than for men.
So that was an interesting finding.
So more important for the women than for the men.
And you can see I've given you a few other things there.
Lots of advantages to exercise.
It makes us healthier overall.
And if you do, athletes,
make sure that this is particularly for type 1 diabetics,
if they're getting ready to play a game
and their glucose is over 300
or over 250 with ketones in their urine, they cannot play
because they have a shortage of insulin.
They need insulin not exercise at that point.
All right, weight loss maintenance.
This has been an odd question that's appeared
and the answer has been to eat breakfast daily.
I don't think that's going to appear anymore.
People have moved around that now
with a lot more eating when you're hungry
and satiety sort of things.
Monitoring the weight once a week is really important.
And they tend to try to put in there
that you should monitor your weight daily,
and that's not the answer.
The answer is monitor once a week.
So you wanna keep an eye on it,
but you don't have to look at it every day,
your weight changes daily.
I think the other's straightforward.
Okay, let's get to the medicines.
Medicines are indicated for a BMI of 30 or 27
if you have another comorbid condition like diabetes.
So in general,
we're using only the approved weight loss medications.
I'll give you a couple of caveats there.
You need to monitor these every month
for the first three months
and then at least every three months after that.
And only continue weight loss
or continue the medications,
if they're actively losing on the medications.
In prediabetes, we use things like metformin, pioglitazone.
Remember that statins actually
increase your risk of diabetes.
And they are not for weight loss, this is for heart health.
There are things that delay the onset of diabetes.
And that's been a question.
And the answer is lifestyle, lifestyle, lifestyle.
So there are a lot of meds that do it,
but lifestyle is the answer.
The SGLT-2 inhibitors are out there now.
And you're going to see the GLP-1s on that list as well.
In general, if you're picking medications for other things,
pick weight loss type medications.
So if your patient has migraines
and you wanna use migraine prophylaxis,
topiramate is a great choice
because it's a good weight loss drug, okay?
Bupropion if they have depression
because they're gonna be more likely to lose weight on that
than anything else.
And then again, the GLP-1s and the SGLT-2s.
We're gonna talk a lot about those today.
A 57-year-old female with a BMI of 37 has tried
six months of intensive behavioral weight management
and has only lost seven pounds.
Seen that a few times.
She's adequately treated hypertension and diabetes
with an A1c in the eight range.
What would be her best choice for weight loss?
Topiramate, phentermine, orlistat, or semaglutide?
This should take all of three seconds to answer.
You bet, semaglutide.
And these drugs are revolutionizing what we're doing.
Okay, so these are the licensed weight loss medications.
Orlistat, it's been out there for a long time.
It blocks a breakdown of fat in the gut,
and so you don't absorb fats,
so they go out in your bowels,
along with all kinds of bacteria
and there's all kinds of GI side effects.
Weight loss is fairly moderate with this,
but it can be used long term.
I will tell you that over the counter,
it works just as well as the prescription.
And you can get this, it's called Alli,
you can get it pretty much any place.
Okay, bupropion and naltrexone,
that combination, these drugs are actually pretty expensive.
They cost, these you know are costing
the five, $600 range, interestingly.
And they work reasonably well.
Again, you can use bupropion anyway,
but the combination works a little better.
It works pretty well for those people
who kind of tend to, you know,
like when they do eat, they just eat too much.
And that, you know,
the ones that they, I don't, you know,
I eat three meals a day.
Well, you eat, you know, some of them too big.
So this is a reasonable drug in that category.
Okay, phentermine has been around for a long, long time
and it is the only cheap medication on the list.
And it's an amphetamine derivative.
You can see we usually use it
at doses up to 37.5 milligrams a day.
There is a new formulation now that's eight milligrams.
And so using that
in combination with phentermine or with topiramate
will sometimes give you pretty much the same thing
as the phentermine topiramate Qsymia combination.
And because again, that drug costs about $600
and isn't very often covered by their insurance.
Until the new injectable medications came out,
this was really the best one on the list.
The side effects are the mostly from the topiramate.
And so patients feel a little odd on topiramate sometimes.
So sometimes you have to start that dose pretty low.
So the GLP-1s.
GLP-1 is a substance in your blood or in your,
it's secreted from the pancreas
and it helps you to secrete insulin.
It increases satiety, it slows gastric emptying,
so your stomach feels full longer.
And often it is full longer.
There are, we have to talk about the complications of this.
So the first drug out in this category
that was used for weight loss was liraglutide,
it's a daily injection.
And so then semaglutide came out
and it's a weekly injection.
That's a lot easier sell for people.
So, and people are lining up like crazy to get these drugs.
But look at that, 86.4% have at least a 5% weight loss.
We had nothing that gave this in the past.
So out of the gate, this was,
this quickly became a high demand drug.
Tirzepatide is the newest, it's a GLP-1,
and a glucagon-dependent insulinotropic peptide.
So it works in two different ways.
And you can look at the average weight loss there of 21%.
So this is a, look,
and there is a third generation coming out
that will work in three ways.
It's a GLP-1, a GIP, and another mechanism.
And so we're gonna see these drugs just pound the market.
Zepbound came out.
So tirzepatide has been out, as Mounjaro for diabetes,
it came out as Zepbound in December.
Most insurance companies are not covering it yet.
So, but that will happen over the next few months.
Weight loss medications in children and adolescents.
The pediatrics association is really pushing
to get medications into children,
to get to think about bariatric options for children,
about bariatric surgery.
Because we know that when children are obese as children
and maintain that obesity into adulthood,
they have increased morbidity and mortality
throughout their lifetimes so.
In children, medication options are orlistat,
the phentermine topiramate,
and both liraglutide and semaglutide.
And I'm sure that tirzepatide will join that list soon.
This is just really quickly,
I wanted to tell you about this gastric balloon
because you may see it.
They're using it in odd places,
like I've seen plastic surgery offices using this.
And you put a balloon down into the stomach
and fill it up with water,
so it fills up the stomach and effectively makes you have,
you know, it's kind of a bariatric surgery alternative.
And then after about three to four months,
the balloon usually bursts
and then is passed out in the feces.
Sometimes it gets caught
and they have to surgically retrieve it.
So there are some complications with this.
And it really has never become mainline,
but I just wanted you to know it's out there.
Okay, let's talk about bariatric surgery.
It is the most effective form of weight loss.
And don't be surprised if you see that question.
It's not the best form, it's the most effective form.
If you do bariatric surgery, people lose weight.
It's very effective.
It's a very effective option
for treatment of type 2 diabetes.
And it has reduced all cause mortality,
particularly cardiac mortality.
And so people do better after bariatric surgery.
It's indicated with a BMI of
greater than 40 or greater than 35 with other complications
or greater than 30 with uncontrolled diabetes.
So, you should offer it after everything else has failed.
So you should try medications first.
It's high risk for obesity related,
anybody who's at high risk
for obesity related morbidity and mortality.
Generally indicated between the ages of 18 and 65,
but they've really pushed the ranges on this.
And you can see the contraindications there,
substance use, end stage disease.
So any kind of end stage organ disease is
gonna be contraindicated.
But look at the outcomes,
80% less likely develop diabetes
and all less major adverse liver outcomes,
adverse cardiac outcomes,
much more mean weight loss with this
as compared to a non-surgical group.
So this is a very effective form of treatment.
You have a 46-year-old considering a sleeve gastrectomy,
what should you tell her is the most likely complication
in the first six months?
Pulmonary embolus, GERD, reoperation, or dumping syndrome?
All right, good, GERD.
The dumping syndrome is not that common.
It does occur,
but it's not nearly as common as some of these other things.
So first of all,
the complications right after bariatric surgery
are actually very low.
The lowest complication rate is with the sleeve gastrectomy,
which has now become the number one treatment
in bariatric surgery.
Notice that now sleeve gastrectomy or Roux-en-Y,
either one can be done laparoscopically.
And so that's really moved this area of medicine forward.
But please know the number one cause of death,
cause of death not complication,
but cause of death immediately following bariatric surgery
is pulmonary embolus.
And that's a question that's frequently asked,
so please know that.
Okay, the biggest complications, right?
It depends on where you look.
GERD and gallbladder problems.
And a lot of cases they'll take out the gallbladder
when they do the surgery
because when you lose weight you have gallbladder problems.
So how much of it is from the bariatric surgery itself
and how much of it is from
the weight loss that occurs after.
It all gets lost in the mass.
But those two things are going to be
your greatest complication rates.
So dumping syndrome is not that common
and it's going to be much more common in bypass procedures,
like in Roux-en-Y not in a sleeve gastrectomy.
Nutritional deficiencies,
please know it's iron deficiency.
That's the number one nutritional deficiency.
We talk about a lot of others, but that's the number one.
You can see some of the other issues there.
So this is the sleeve gastrectomy.
They just basically make the stomach a tube
and in doing that they get rid of the antrum of the stomach.
And so they also get rid of,
that's where most of the hunger hormone ghrelin comes from.
And because you don't have any ghrelin,
then you get hungry less often.
And so that's an added benefit of the sleeve gastrectomy.
The weight loss tends to be a little slower
than with a Roux-en-Y.
There's not a malabsorptive component here,
so you tend to get fewer of the deficiencies
or things like dumping syndrome that sort of thing.
Here's the Roux-en-Y.
You make the stomach really small,
you cut the end of the duodenum,
you bring it up and attach it to the stomach.
And then you have to attach that whole stomach,
first part of the duodenum back in
because that's where
all of our digestive juices come from, right?
So you have to get that all back in there.
But note that this is the recommended surgery
in patients with pre-existent GERD.
This is an A recommendation
and has already been asked on the In-Training Exam.
So please know that.
After bariatric surgery, avoid NSAIDs.
For a while they were saying
you could never take NSAIDs again
if you had bariatric surgery.
They really relaxed that.
But for the first few months after bariatric surgery,
you need to have no NSAIDs,
insulin secretagogues like the sulfonylureas,
try to get patients off of anything like that.
You're gonna decrease your insulin doses
because they're gonna lose weight
and their diabetes is gonna get in better control.
You can't use extended release
or enteric-coated medications.
So you're gonna need to look
through their whole medication group
and make sure you get them off of those
extended release medications.
And pregnancy should be avoided for at least a year
following bariatric surgery.
So meal recommendations, they need to eat small amounts,
they need to, they can't,
it's all they can eat.
And they need to eat their protein first
so they make sure they get their protein.
You don't consume liquids when you're eating your meals.
And then the vitamin supplementation is probably indefinite.
Labs, you have to get frequent labs in the first year.
Then there's a lot of controversy about
how often we should be getting these.
Right now, the recommendation is yearly
after the first couple of years.
But look at all of those things,
all of those vitamins and the supplementation.
They're also backing off on the supplementation
on some of these things
and not looking for some of them like copper for instance,
for a while they were looking for all of these
on a regular basis.
And please note that they should have a bone density
a couple of years after their bariatric surgery as well.
So bariatric surgery works.
60 to 80% of obese patients have
complete resolution of their diabetes.
And 30% still had resolution at 15 years with Roux-en-Y.
That's a pretty amazing.
And the mortality rate is three to four times higher
in patients treated with oral medications in diabetes
as opposed to those who have bariatric surgery.
It saves lives for people who are morbidly obese.
All right, we're gonna quickly talk
about screening for diabetes.
The USPSTF recommends screening for diabetes
in which of the following groups?
All persons age 35 to 70 who are overweight,
all persons with a BMI greater than 30,
all obese persons beginning at age 35,
or all children above the 80th per 85th percentile.
Okay, this one's very important.
It's a USPSTF recommendation.
So everybody, 35 to 70 who's overweight or obese.
And also the ADA recommends screening all women
with gestational diabetes at four to 12 weeks postpartum.
These are the ADA recommendations.
You can look at those.
I just want you to know that these have been
the recommendations for screening for diabetes in children,
but the USPSTF just came out with a grade I,
there's insufficient evidence for screening
for diabetes in children.
So that's what you'll need to know.
These are just some prevention things for diabetes.
Again, it's lifestyle and weight loss.
And those are the practice recommendations.
So thank you very much.
Thank you very much, Dr. Vail.
(bright music)